what do you mean
people like to hate on smoking
cigarettes cigarettes suck
cigarettes suck because and i worked for
[ __ ] marlboro
i know you worked for marlborough with
leo burnett you did a whole like ad
campaign for them right yeah you
designed what did you do for them
uh the displays behind the counter that
like the
at the convenience store when you go you
know where all the cigarettes are yeah
so like you know they have like the big
banner up top it's like
marlborough yeah yeah yeah i designed
two of those that went nationwide that's
[ __ ]
like all like the [ __ ] signage for
every convenience store in the country
are yours did you ever go into a store
and see one of your designs oh yeah
that's [ __ ] sick yeah i remember came
home one time i went to the corner store
and
i got a picture of me behind the camera
really yeah hell yes
hitting it like that yeah cigarettes
suck cigarettes are underrated though
they brainwash you dude no no yeah yeah
i get all that
but having a cigarette every once in a
while
nice yeah can we agree with that i can
agree on a cigar
what about a cigarette no no no because
it's like the larry david thing you
smoke a cigarette different than you
smoke a cigar and you're smoking a
cigarette you're like
ah you know it's like it's like a thing
you know it's like there's like a thing
to it like
you take a big a big [ __ ] hit of a
cigarette you inhale it
and it gives you a little bit of a head
rush and you get like energy from it
gives you like it
gets the neurons fired up in your head
like
when i smoke a cigarette when shane
comes over that's just the oxygen
cutting off and you're [ __ ] getting
light-headed in that big-ass [ __ ]
dome
that's what that is no bro i'm telling
you when shane comes over and i
i smoke one of his new ports before you
before you do someone like the crazy
podcast
i'll feel like more just dialed in and
laser focused when after i smoke a
cigarette
something about the the nicotine i don't
know if it's the nicotine i don't know
what the
chemicals or the sciences of it but
something about it just like
really gets me [ __ ] on fire just one
all i need is one you should start
smoking more one
no i mean you don't need to start
smoking you don't need to i mean if you
go and buy a pack of cigarettes you've
gone too far
but it's okay to bum them it's okay to
have a cigarette
on occasion like if you go out
to a bar so you're saying if you feel
like you get it from somebody it doesn't
count
exactly but like where does that line
stop
oh i don't have the bag on me but i'm
gonna just go do a couple bumps
that gives me a lot of energy too oh
it's not
oh these aren't my pills i just took one
from my friend it is about the same it's
yeah yeah you could say it's the same
thing like you're you're not buying
you're not buying this [ __ ] i didn't
spend any money on it yeah you didn't
spend any money on it
you just benefited from it but i could
say like doing a couple bumps
when you're drunk is beneficial if you
gotta if you gotta drive home and you're
wasted
you gotta do a couple bumps to get you
home what's the
what's the harm in that where's the
heart where's the
i mean you're not doing it every day
you're not abusing it you're not a
cokehead
i'm not buying it yeah you're not buying
it i'm not holding it you're not holding
it
you're not selling it you're not
whatever i mean i think cocaine should
be illegal
i mean legal cocaine should be legal why
do you think it should be legal
because if it was legal it'd be safer if
it was regulated by the [ __ ] fda and
the government said hey
you want to buy cocaine yeah you can you
can do you know you can get prescribed
cocaine
i learned that on a podcast cool you can
get prescribed cocaine legally where
anywhere like it's a there's a medical
condition i forget what the [ __ ] it is
right now
maybe you can look it up producer
there's a way you can go to the doctor
and if you have a certain medical
condition you can get prescribed
cocaine i was listening to a podcast i
have anxiety does that does that work
like with a weed card
uh hamilton pharmaceutical you know
hamilton who has the show about doing
drugs yeah
he said it he said that he met a guy
hamilton said it yeah he's kind of
he's a drug god he's the drug lord he's
the drug lord he's the drug
overlord yeah but no no if
cocaine was regulated and it was safe
and wasn't cut by some
[ __ ] lord in his in in a trap house
cutting it with [ __ ] borax and it was
actually safe to
use under certain circumstances
like a cocaine bar not recreation
recreational were you talking about like
a hookah
there was a limit if you're [ __ ] up i
mean
it'll blow your mind the amount of
people that
sweet penis and her cousins know that
are like in their 20s that do cocaine
every night of the week it blows my mind
everybody does coke it's insane still
like even i never know my life's age so
i'm still doing it i never realized why
why do you need to be 60 years old doing
coke yours is a [ __ ] death wish bro
dude i never realized how many people
did it yeah
it's everywhere [ __ ] insane yeah it
really blows your mind when you go out
somewhere casually
and you just see people like doing coke
or you like see people in the bathroom
you see a baggie somewhere or you see
like
somebody about you're just casually
going to the bathroom and you hear
somebody they stall doing it yes
like why does this surprise me so much
yeah we're the weird ones because we
don't do it anymore right we don't do it
anyway yeah but it's
it's so surprising like but when we did
it or when i used to do it like back in
the day when we were younger and we'd go
into a [ __ ]
bathroom stall and sneak a couple bumps
in i always thought like we were [ __ ]
breaking some crazy law or we were being
so deceptive
but now i go to a bar and people don't
even give a [ __ ] no they do it right out
in the open
in line to go to the bathroom yeah you
don't even need a stall anymore it's
just a little
whatever so what i'm saying is like if
it was if it was legal
and all of the [ __ ] was it was safer and
not cut with like really dangerous
things
and you know it was regulated like if
you didn't have to go to it was
taxed and regulated it was taxed and
regulated maybe
your doctor only gives you uh an eight
ball a month
and you've got a ball i gotta conserve
this eight ball for the month
that ain't happening boys i tell you
that much that eight volume lasting
all day that's the po that's the problem
with it that's the problem once you
start you can't
stop mm-hmm was it one's two minutes too
many in a mill and a thousand ain't
enough
million boys a millionaire that's a fact
dude i don't understand how so many
people like the guy [ __ ] billy corbin
interview the old school people who like
from hollywood
these movie producers people who make
all these famous documentaries they
claim they've never done cocaine
yeah i don't know i mean there are
people out there but i feel like
i don't believe them a lot of people
just aren't coming to terms with the
truth of
their past addictions or maybe they're
still doing and they're just like oh no
i don't do that
yeah how are you going to be around all
that and like do the film and like not
be a part of it like don't you want to
see what all the fuss is about
[Laughter]
no you don't need that
you made the cocaine cowboys documentary
they're one of the most famous cocaine
real life documentaries in the history
of and you're connected with like
this you live in miami the best cocaine
in the world is just like coming to you
and you're like
you know more about the connections than
anybody
but never had the interest to
just give it a whirl got some willpower
if that's true
that's some more power or some shitty
lying
what do you think do you think he was
lying yeah i do
you don't believe him i don't believe
him i feel like you can see through
people i feel like
once you do drugs and like you talk to
people about doing drugs you can see it
i think when you make eye contact with
somebody like you can tell if they've
like
been in it it's weird because everyone
likes to talk like
no one has shame in talking about doing
any other kind of drugs like
like smoking pot taking mushrooms doing
acid those kind of drugs like the
psychedelic drugs
but when it comes to uppers nobody it's
like they avoid it like the plague
nobody wants to admit to taking them
what do you think that is i don't know
why that is
but nobody wants to admit to ever trying
cocaine
i think it's just got such like a stigma
to it yeah why
it's just the the way that it's talked
about
in the news and the way people it's not
it's disgusting
yeah like well i mean like how like you
like hear about it like whenever people
talk about it's like
cocaine is like this like awful thing
and like the drugs led to murder and
then
it is kind of like a gross thing yeah
you snored it it's kind of gross
yeah i don't know it was fun
snoring but i'm really grateful i don't
do it anymore
grateful i did it cool so what that was
all about like i think it's cool that
like we got out of our system early
yeah you know what i mean some people
are nerds and they don't get exposed to
it later until like later in life
yeah like in their 30s or 40s they try
for the first time
and yeah there's so much to ruin at that
point you're trying it that late you're
a [ __ ] loser
yeah but if you if you tried it and got
out of your system in your early 20s
mid-20s then
that's i feel like that's fine i feel
like that's normal i feel like the
people that try it in their 30s or the
people that like
end up like it really hits you hard yeah
because like wow
i've been sleeping on this for way too
long didn't make up for last time yes
and then like you just
lose your entire life completely yeah
instead
you know we almost had some near-death
experiences in our twenties from doing
too much coaching
we learned our lesson we live we went
through the real world we know michael
rappaport's over here no
we're living we're living we're [ __ ]
yeah brother
doing it man
it's a good point i'm not gonna smoke
don't smoke crack don't smoke crack
people smoke cigarettes
cigarettes one cigarette one cigarette
every once in a while occasionally enjoy
a cigarette don't smoke it
don't buy a pack of cigarettes yeah if
you see some
[ __ ] loser who bought a pack of
cigarettes you could bum one of his
cigarettes yeah
without but first that's a good start
criticize them for buying the pack
but then take one yeah take one first
then criticize them because if you make
fun of them as you're smoking it yes
yes so that way like you're on their
level so it's like hey i understand what
you're going through because i'm smoking
too
bro watching mad men made me want to
smoke cigarettes watching people smoke
cigarettes makes me want to smoke
cigarettes
can you relate i mean it's just all the
trigger like it's
again it's just like the habit you see
people smoking and you see people
enjoying it like
it triggers that thing in your brain
it's like oh yeah i do like smoking
cigarettes or oh yeah i do like drinking
or oh yeah i do like [ __ ] doing drugs
like whenever you see people doing it in
movies it
triggers it in you this is my first
what's up world you just watched a clip
from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly pure
uncut content straight from the jungles
of columbia if you want to watch the
full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace
i